de petits arrivages en rien d'inquiétant
pour l'instant ici à lens cafards les
agents municipaux nettoient
régulièrement la plage depuis quinze
jours les algues brunes c'est chou de
façon plus régulière en petit filet on
fait à peu près 5 ou 6 euros contraction
de camions
bonjour j'ai terminé de 14 tommy a déjà
habitué ça fait plus de 50 car il a
besoin pour ya pas de problème à ce
niveau il n'y a pas de problème en écho
à ceux qui descendent gaz stocké à
quelques kilomètres dans les hauteurs de
la commune
rappelez vous en 2014 et 2015 le
littoral a été régulièrement souillé
provoquant des situations inédites
robert par exemple quelques 600 mille
tonnes de st gall ont été enlevés chaque
semaine des familles de punta léry four
à chaux ou de la pointe savanes ont été
fortement incommodées par les émanations
toxiques
depuis les municipalités les plus
touchés ont reçu des aides de l'état et
du fonds européen pour l'achat d'eau
chacun dé quoi nous sommes prêts plus
que nous avons des moyens qui nous a été
alloué par le fonds sud et ans c'est à
dire en 280 mille euros est allouée à la
ville nous a permis d'acheter des
machines au pouvoir enlever les
sérieuses mais si bien sûr les évasions
sont beaucoup plus massive donc la
préfecture pour le relais avec des
moyens plus conséquents une aide de la
préfecture et une aide des communautés
des communes également robert il sera
aussi question d'utiliser en temps voulu
un barrage flottant pour éviter
l'échouage des algues sur le littoral on
l'attend plus que le barrage flottant il
a été testé au mario il normalement on
devait le testo robert mais faute de
sart garçon n'a pas pu la tester donc
c'est un barrage qui devrait
être mis au niveau de pontarlier qui est
une zone sensible qui serait un
kilomètre de long nous avons été
épargnés l'an dernier le serons nous
cette année
pas sûr les spécialistes n'excluent pas
une invasion de ces algues à partir de
mai